so a question that has been going around
ever since Avengers infinity war came
out is do you have to be worthy to lift
Stormbreaker
[Music]
and many of you have asked me my
thoughts on the matter you've asked me
to do a video on it sorry I'm finally
getting around to it just now and the
reason I am is because we actually
finally have an answer just a quick
reminder about the giveaway I am giving
away a few copies of Avengers infinity
war on blu-ray all you have to do to
enter is be subscribed to this channel
like this video comment below with your
favorite superhero so to start this
video off I just want to say that you
have to kind of get rid of whatever
happened in the comics when you think
about this question because this is the
MCU not the comics they completely
change Stormbreaker
and the story behind Stormbreaker
Stormbreaker in the comics was
originally made for a character named
beta ray bill and it was Odin who
commissioned the doors of net of layer
to make it for beta ray bill so right
off the bat neither of those characters
are in Avengers infinity war and not to
mention the storm breaker hammer that
Thor built and Avengers infinity war it
looks nothing like storm breaker in the
comics it actually looks a lot more like
ultimate mule nerrit with groots arm as
a handle so the point being the hammer
is not the same the story is not the
same so you can't refer to the comics
for the answer on this question but for
those of you who were asking what I
thought about it my answer to it would
have been no you do not have to be
worthy to lift it think about the first
Thor movie we literally saw Odin put the
worthiness enchantment on mule near
maybe Thor but I don't think he was
thinking about that in the moment now
Stormbreaker
is made of a room metal so it does have
the capacity to hold in magic very well
but this is very different than an
enchantment the IRRI metal simply has
the ability to magnify magic there is no
spell put on it that we saw however I do
think that you have to be incredibly
powerful to lift it and these ideas have
been confirmed by none other than the
Russo brothers themselves the
researchers took questions at a voodoo
viewing party in which some fans tweeted
them questions and they tweeted back the
answers one fan tweeted them so in the
Ford scene Groot was able to lift
Stormbreaker with that
make group worthy along with Thor and
vision and the risk of brothers replied
mule near requires worthiness not
Stormbreaker the Russo brothers so there
you have it it's officially confirmed
the Russo brothers themselves said it
Stormbreaker does not have a worthiness
enchantment on it but they did talk
about the person needing to be powerful
enough to lift it they got another
question in that asked who else can hold
Stormbreaker since Thor told the
Guardians it killed them which is
exactly why I always thought that not
anybody can just pick it up you have to
be a super powerful beam Thor himself
tells the guardians of the galaxy you
simply lack the strength to wield it
your bodies would crumble as your minds
collapsed into madness so it's very
clear but the Russo brothers cleared it
up by answering the question by saying
there are few people as strong as or
stronger than Thor and you know who some
of them are rusev brothers the first
person that comes to my mind when I hear
this is Thanos himself and then the next
person is hella because we've already
seen her destroy me linear so there you
have it it is officially confirmed by
the Russo brothers themselves Zorin
breaker does not have a worthiness
enchantment on it and you do have to be
super powerful in order to wield it who
do you all think is strong enough to
wield Stormbreaker let me know what you
think in the comments below and again a
reminder about our giveaway all you have
to do to enter for your chance to get a
free copy of Avengers infinity war
blu-ray is subscribe to this channel
like this video and comment below with
your favorite superhero thank you so
much for watching woof woof
[Music]